[Music]
thank you
for tuning into the dean show all right
today we're going to be talking about
very important topic all of the topics
are so important
because during every show most of the
shows we keep
stimulating a person to think to think
and ponder
to get away from the rat race of life to
stop and ponder what's my purpose in
life why am i here
where am i going when i die deaf is a
reality avoiding it is not going to make
it
go away so you kind of put a hold on all
the entertainment and now you come to
the more serious issues talking about
god the creator doing good deeds what
are good deeds
how to accomplish paradise well that's
infinity you live forever
but now it has to be based on proof and
evidences
so god almighty he has sent evidences
with all these messenger
yours that he sent through time they all
came a with a simple message
avoid worshiping false gods men woman
money this that and the other that are
part of the creation and only worship
the one who
created you the one god and they all
came with proofs and evidences and the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
he came with evidences and proofs but
now the interesting things we've covered
this in other shows
he came with the quran verbatim word of
god scientific facts prophecies and all
these other things
but now we have him god almighty has
left remnants evidences in the bible
actually
yes muhammad peace be upon him is also
prophesied
in the bible and that evidence we're
going to be giving you today
here on the dean show don't go nowhere
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
likewise likewise you have your own
section at the deanshow.com people can
go there and see some of the other shows
that we've done
we've covered a lot of evidences and
proofs
to show indeed that islam is a way of
life from no other but the creator of
the heavens and earth
and one of those was the scientific
miracles in the quran
you know all the different historical
facts all the different facts and not
fiction that
one cannot come to any other conclusion
that this quran is indeed from the
creator that has an earth this is the
ultimate proof
that if anyone wants to know they just
have to open up this book and read
and ask the one who created them god
almighty to guide them
but now the interesting part and that is
what makes this topic so interesting
that
some people would think okay bible
that's for the christians and
you know the old testament the first
five books for the for the jewish people
and how do you get muhammad in there and
how are you using it as a proof was he
really in the bible are there evidence
pointing that
he is a prophet that's coming that's in
the bible is this
something that you're pulling a fast one
on us or is this the ultimate truth
we're not pulling any fast ones and
actually if you go back to your books
you'll find out that these are the
actual facts
and truth inshaallah we'll start with
the journey let's start with the journey
that the prophecy is actually that is
mentioned
that there will be this man that is
coming from paran
that will be coming from t-man and we'll
take about that we'll talk about these
two specific
words that where is this place and where
is that actual uh
the bedrock of islam where did the
migration take place
if you go to habakkuk 3-3 you'll find
out that actually it says god
that his guidance comes from the man
to the mount from the quran
you'll find out that these two names
specifically will have to cross
reference them in the dictionary of the
explanation of the bible these are
christian scholars that actually will
tell you this paran
paran is actually mecca this area called
makkah
that peran in itself in another language
in arabic which is close to the the
jewish
language the hebrew which is called
pharaon farah meaning the two that the
fled
and who actually fled in that area was
hagar the mother of
ishmael the son of prophet abraham may
peace be upon him and they settled in
that area
so the bible says that that person the
guidance of god
will come from that area born in that
area settled in that area
as ishmael was the prince of arabia and
he's even is mentioned in another that
sons of
ishmael is kedar and he was actually
settled in that area so the proof is
there that they will come from that area
and uh migration they actually talked
about it when it says that area that was
going to be timon
t-mon is actually proven in again some
of the
description or the some of the
dictionaries he says it's north of
medina
another uh interpretation it says
also mentioned in the bible and if you
go back and find out it will be just
north of medina
so now we have a source where this
person is going to come
and where this person is going to end up
so let us cross reference
who is this person that was coming from
peran
meaning in this area mecca and the bible
mentioned sometimes basha or bakka
becca in arabic notes comes from also
those who cry a lot
which is also another name for mecca so
we now know the prophet muhammad may be
spanish was born in mecca no one denies
that fact
and he is the descendant of ishmael may
peace be upon him
and when he migrated he migrated to
medina
after he was driven out being persecuted
and so on and the story is long it's not
our topic now we won't be going into it
but when we know that this incident
specifically mentioned in the bible that
that person
the god's guidance will come from there
paran i'm going to to tim on the mount
when we know that prophet muhammad
actually used to go
actually in that part of that mount so
the proof is there
that he used to go there he came from
there and he's going to
tima or and now two narrations actually
indicate the same place which is north
of menina as a matter of fact the jews
knew this very well
and they migrated to medina specifically
for that purpose
because they knew this was a place that
the prophet that was waiting they were
waiting for
is going to migrate for that they used
to go and actually uh
scare the austrias these are the two
tribes of that used to live in madina
says there was a prophet coming up
and when he comes up and when he is
appears we will follow him and we will
kill you and so on that's what the
children of israel were saying to the
others
absolutely and why would they leave
their beautiful green luscious
uh place of israel and they come to the
sand
the sandy desert of medina where is
nothing they were expecting
the messiah they were expecting the
messiah they were expecting this prophet
that they were actually waiting for
long time ago even some other people
when they used to go to the
uh medina they wanted to fight these
people he says you will not be able to
beat these people because
this is a place where prophet is going
to migrate to
another place in isaiah he says now the
burden of arabia what is this talking
about this is this
arabia will carry the burden burden of
what carrying this message
of the of the quran of islam and he says
that
believe it or not there is another
prophecy that
people will come on asses which is every
student in uh in the bible in the sunday
bible classes will tell you that this
was jesus christ may peace be upon him
but there was another prophets that will
be have the two horsemen says i would
say they will see him on camels
so who was that person that actually
traveled on camels from this area
to from peran which is makkah
to timon or tima which is madinah except
prophet muhammad may peace be upon him
and believe it or not the scholars will
tell you that jesus may peace be upon
him never
went to peran he never went to mecca in
his lifetime so it could not have been
issa here the tamil asses the donkeys
the donkeys when he took the isa maybe
islam took the donkeys but prophet
sallam says took the camels
which was actually mentioned in the
bible that that is a prophecy that will
come
and of course we know that this is just
the beginning
and we know that the migration was
actually mentioned
that they will be guided and there is a
proof
that that man will be coming to medina
and believe it or not the revelation
will come
in uh in isaiah 29 19 to a man that
he will be delivered the book will be
delivered to the prophet who
he says it says read i pray thee
three he says what do i read
he says i am not learned it's this says
in this is in the bible it's in the
bible it's in isaiah 21
29 12. if you can go back and check you
will find out this
is a book that was mentioned be taken by
a prophet and this prophet
will be told read and he will say what
do i read i am not learned
and who is known for that is actually
only prophet muhammed is mentioned the
quran is mentioned the bible when
gabriel may peace be upon him came down
to tell him
read recite first words that was
mentioned in the quran which actually
says
what do i read i am not learned so it
coincides exactly the
uh prophecies in the bible presides
exactly with the
source of prophet muhammad bibi bottom's
birth where he was going to migrate
how he will take and there's so much
more of course to share that we will
have after the break
we're going to be right back with more
here on the d show subhanallah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
akbar
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
it's a way of life brought to
us the messenger
best of men can show
us the way to allah's grace
this is the dean
[Music]
back here on the dean show and we're
talking about muhammad peace be upon him
who's the last and final messenger sent
to mankind
the proofs that indeed we know
that he was a messenger of god and we
have covered so many
different proofs and evidences but now
we're going and
dipping into the bible to show even from
there that those
signs the evidences are even there so
can you continue on were you left off
of course even if you go to deuteronomy
18 18 you will find out that
god almighty was talking to moses maybe
he's upon him he says i will raise him
up to be like
unto thee prophet like unto thee from
their brethren he will speak in my name
he will say i will put it into his words
you see so we'll find out let's
cross-reference who is this
prophet that god almighty was talking to
moses may peace upon him
from 1818 deuteronomy people usually say
it's jesus
but we say was jesus made peace but what
i'm like unto moses moses may peace be
upon him or
was it prophet muhammad may peace upon
him and if you go into the the evidence
and the
the to compare who is closer you'll find
hands down
that prophet muhammad may peace upon him
was like moses
he was a king of islam he was accepted
as a prophet unlike jesus may be upon
him it was not accepted by his people
he was actually born of a mother and a
father just like a
moses unlike isa alayhis was born
miraculously as we believe him to be
burden of a virgin mary immaculate
conception
normal intervention and the way that
actually ended according to them he was
ascended
to heavens or some other people other
faith i believe he was crucified of
course
as muslims we don't believe in that
because god almighty says he killed them
not nor crucified him not
but just to compare the words he was
married jesus christ was not married
muhammad and me
moses my peeps one were married they had
children jesus christ maybe
did not have a children and so many
other ones that there is absolutely no
comparison whatsoever
except that one but he also said their
brethren who is their brethren
because we know that the uh abraham may
be spanish is the patriarch of the
three monotheist religion you know
christianity judaism and islam
and he had two children of course among
them is isaac and
uh and ishmael may be spawning so when
we say the brethren meaning
the brethren from isaac the jews and the
brethren from
ishmael is the arabs it was mentioned as
the prince of the arabs
and from that is the descendant of
prophet muhammad salla
which coincides with everything that is
being prophesized
not to mention that even isa alayhi
salaam he said i have so many things to
say unto you
but you cannot bear them now but when he
the spirit of truth i know it's
mentioned as a comforter or the spirit
of truth or the
or the heli on all that we're not gonna
go into the differences even
if the latin aramaic language and so on
but we'll just take the evidence
it is expedient for me to let me go so i
can send them
so what who was he talking to he will
teach you all the truth he will guide
you to what to the to the
to the righteous path and he will do all
these
great things for you change people
around and and and
who was that when you talk to the the
christians they will tell you this was
the holy spirit
yeah amazingly enough when you quest
reference this he says that you will
find out that jesus christ may be spawn
upset
that you will have to let me go in order
for me to send him
if i'm not going i can't send him so
that was a condition
but you go back in the bible you'll find
out that even the holy spirit what was
john
the baptist with two years ahead of he
was a cousin and he was also in the womb
and so on so he was there before
jesus made peace upon him that could not
be the holy spirit even if the holy
spirit
was there what did he teach you he will
tell you nothing but this
specific verse says he will teach you
all these things he will guide you the
truth and will guide you to all of that
so who was that it could not be anybody
else except prophet muhammad nisman
because he said i will put my words into
him
so he says who speaks in the in the
words god almighty says i will put my
words unto him
the only prophet muhammad bison all the
time bismillah
in the name of god so he speaks in the
name of god
the most mercenary this is how the quran
is recited correct
so you say he is god one and only this
is
what the bible you're referencing to the
bible and then the quran that's right
because god almighty says to moses i
will put my words unto him
he will not speak on his own as a matter
of fact the quran says
he does not speak of his own whims and
desires it is only revelation is
bestowed on to him
so all the evidence is actually
indicating that that verse in the 18 18
deuteronomy that moses may peace be upon
him was told by prophet
by allah that he will have another
prophet raised from the brethren meaning
isaac and ishmael and the son of ishmael
of course the prophet muhammad
bought him in that place that we too we
said from coming to timon
from makkah to medina the proof is there
and the evidence is
is abundant that's that's amazing
because even this when god almighty is
saying say
the prophet muhammad didn't leave this
out verbatim he said what
the creator told him to say even these
things he didn't leave out
it's called
is the prophet muhammad peace be upon
him is he mentioned by name anywhere in
the bible
he is mentioned by name in the song of
solomon 5 16
even though that some of the people will
actually tell you know muhammadim you
know it is
that is true and uh but but he was
talking about uh some
love story his lips are sweet to hear
you the daughter of israel
and so on no regardless he is actually
mentioned by name
he is mentioned by name isla if you if
you punch in uh if you punch him you
actually translate the
hebrew into this and you will find out
that exactly what it's mentioned but
i've actually talked to rabbi this is
mentioned by name
and he is they are known they are known
for that that even
god almighty uh mentioned that in the
quran that he will be
called in the quran says ahmed and some
of the people try to actually coincide
with that
whether it's uh it's the case or not it
is mentioned by name literally it is
true
in a concept in the context of what
story that they they say it's a
different context why would he be saying
it but he's actually literally mentioned
by name in the song of solomon is 5 16
is there but now we go further
when we find out that even
ishmael may peace be upon him was
promised by god almighty
that you will have the greater nation
you see from the isaac and ishmael by
god almighty promise
that ishmael will have the greater
nation who is the greater nation that is
the ascendant of ishmael
except muslims and who is the only one
that actually came in and
changed his whole world around and told
you what to do told you not what to do
his life was looked by a microscope
every aspect everything he told
us to do islam is a way of life we have
everything there's utterance a way to
follow etiquettes and matters
from the day you wake up in the morning
till the day you sleep it coincides
again
with what is mentioned in the in the
bibles not to mention of course there
are so many
uh things that are mentioned in the
bible regarding prophet muhammad
meebispalam
in his migration not only his migration
in some of the battles
in some of the verses in the bible it
says those ill-equipped
few beat the mighty men of kidar
who is kidar is actually the second son
of ishmael is mentioned in the bible
that actually settled in that haram with
the mountains which mentioned is mecca
and these were the people of quraish and
these were that
children ishmael did not heed to the
message
and prophet muhammad made peace be upon
him after he was driven
out from mecca to medina he came with
only 313
really equipped people were they were
not coming to fight
but the other ones came in with 900 and
so close to a thousand
fighters and they were coming to fight
and the bible says that these ill few
men beat the strong mighty men
of the the children of gerard this is
the bible the bible is saying this and
if you go back and cross reference
you'll find out that is the first battle
which is the battle of badr where
miraculously by the blessing of god
almighty
god almighty gave the ill few which is
313 or 314
to beat those close to a thousand
fighters that came to fight
even though these ones were only came
back to take some what belongs to them
not to fight but that is one the other
battle that was actually mentioned
believe it or not was the battle of badr
of badlav
it was uh when when the archers was
mentioned and
those were given the rights and that's
the strength that will will show on
not to mention the ten thousand that was
mentioned in the bible
it will be in the bible in the bible is
mentioned that he will have ten thousand
of righteous disciples
and which one is that this is the ten
thousand
that came with prophet muhammad may
peace be upon him where
to go back to conquest of mecca and they
were
actually told go you're free
so everything that actually coincides
with the numbers with the place
with the stories with the utterance with
the proof
is all belongs and points to prophet
muhammad may peace be upon him
we're going to take a break and we're
going to come back to finish off
muhammad in the bible sit tight i'm
going away
islam it's killing of innocent human
beings
human life is precious
[Music]
it's a way of life brought to
us by the messenger
best of men can show us the way
to allah's grace this is the dean
dean of islam
[Music]
back here on the dean's show we're
talking about muhammad peace be upon him
who was a messenger like jesus moses
abraham noah they all came with the same
message worship
one god worship the creator of all that
exists do not worship what he created
and obey the messengers and the last the
final messenger sent to mankind today is
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
no more messages are coming and
evidences are even in the bible but
someone says you know what sheikh
tell us if you guys don't do you believe
in the bible now is that the word of god
how are you taking this in evidence
if this is not your holy book if this is
not the book that you believe is from
god
what do we believe about the bible we
believe in the bible we do believe there
is in it
there's a word of god and in it there's
a word of historian in it there's a word
of the prophet that ain't it there are
certain things that's not be fitting
uh to be in it you know if we go into
this topic
it's big but however we take some of the
evidence that actually coincides because
god almighty actually says
bring your proof so we can press
reference from your own book we say look
it's in your own fingertips that you can
actually see it but people when they
have a preconceived
idea or don't want to believe because
they're holding on to a certain belief
that this is their only salvation they
don't want to come with the
the rights that comes in with islam what
to do what not to do
they will actually let go they don't
want to believe they just were told
that to believe in certain things and
that's your way of salvation why bother
why do you have to go and to make your
life difficult
you know do and don'ts and restrictions
and all that but it's all for your own
good
because the difficult part about it
again if you go back to deuteronomy 18
and up to 19 you'll find out that is not
really up to you
my brothers and sisters whether you like
it or not we are created for a reason
and god almighty says
but he the one that i'm sending he says
if you do not hearken unto his message
that i will require it meaning i will be
revenging
it so it is not a choice if you know the
truth
and if you know the truth you cannot
turn a blind eye be honest with yourself
my dear brothers and sisters out there
and at least when you know the proof is
there is mentioned and everything points
to prophet muhammad may peace be upon
him
in all aspects with a lot more detail
than
most people thought that you have to
come back and face yourself
save yourself in this life so you'll
have a better future you will have a
good life
and you have a better future just in a
couple minutes that we have left
you have given the evidence that indeed
even the signs that prophet muhammad
peace be upon him
was coming that he's the last final
messenger is in the bible
but this way of life that we live islam
simply means to acquire
peace by submitting yourself to the
owner of peace the one god and a muslim
is one who does islam
prayer praying to god charity the
pilgrimage to mecca fasting
is islam in the bible if you look at it
if you
eloquently explain muhammad in the bible
is the rest of
the components of islam the facets of
islam are they even in the bible
of course everything that comes from the
same source comes with the same things
we all know that we believe in all the
divine scriptures all prophets and
messengers because they come from the
same source
god almighty so if you look at the
context of all the divine scriptures you
will find it is the same
you will find the messages you know god
almighty is one
we know all the prophets and messengers
preached there's only one god there's
only only one
way of life that turns around and
changes these things where they come
from there is no proof and we know that
it is not in the original bible and how
could all the prophets and messengers
preach something else that is not
actually there because god almighty is
divisive and so on it doesn't make sense
to anything
so god almighty puts it back and that's
why the quran is called the criterion
the quran the one that actually tells
you on the end of uh
you know the factory line and says this
is right this is not right and so on so
we say that even then you will find out
that jesus christ made this upon him
when he prayed he placed his uh
his forehead to the ground he prayed he
was there he used to face a certain
direction in the east and he was
actually used to fast and so on
so everything the ten commandments
everything is coincides because it comes
from the same source
god almighty so it doesn't mean that you
will have a terrible life no
not the case the case is that even ali
maybe he's be upon him and all the
prophets and messenger i mean
and his family prophet saw that maybe
he's believed him what do you say he's a
man coming up
he says you know what if there's no
nothing in the hereafter what happens
what if you guys just made yourself very
difficult you lowered your gaze you
didn't lie you didn't steal
you fasted you you didn't drink and you
prayed and you pilgrimage and give your
money to charity the poor
what if you all these restrictions in
the end you find out there is nothing
he says if there was absolutely nothing
in the end
at least of would have had a good life
good
righteous wholesome life but what if
there is
something in the end who would be the
loss and do you want to really take a
chance
of course not this is amazing amazing
for any
true seeker who's sincere and wants to
know the truth the truth is there and
the truth shall
set you free we started with peace we
end with peace may god almighty the
creator allah reward you thank you
sheikh pleasure as always thank you oh
yeah
and there you have it more evidence upon
evidence continue to come to the dean's
show
and look at some of the previous shows
we've done science you want it it's
there it's in the quran
facts not fiction the preservation of
this book the quran
like no other book has been recited
for years and years from fourteen
hundred years plus years
in the same way that we had it then we
have it today
evaluate it read it call the number on
the screen one eight hundred six six
two islam to get a free copy of the
quran and to learn
more ask your questions even your
criticisms are welcome so we can have a
healthy dialogue but don't just sit
there and wait for death to approach
and then you've had your shot it's over
seek these questions important questions
what's the purpose of life
why have i been created why am i here
and who best to tell you but the one who
created this whole universe and
everything
in it the same god that jesus called
upon that he prayed to
that's the god that we're calling you to
call upon to ask for the guidance
ask for the guidance as we said earlier
the true self
set you free we'll see you next time
here in the show until then peace be
unto you
[Music]
the name this is
[Music]